the following is a conversation with Sam
Altman CEO of openai the company behind
gpt4 Chad GPT Dolly codex and many other
AD Technologies which both individually
and together constitute some of the
greatest breakthroughs in the history of
artificial intelligence Computing and
Humanity in general
please allow me to say a few words about
the possibilities and the dangers of AI
in this current moment in the history of
human civilization
I believe it is a critical moment we
stand on the precipice of fundamental
societal transformation where soon
nobody knows when but many including me
believe it's within our lifetime the
collective intelligence of the human
species begins to pale in comparison by
many orders of magnitude to the general
super intelligence in the AI systems we
build and deploy
at scale
this is both exciting and terrifying it
is exciting because of the innumerable
applications we know and don't yet know
that will Empower humans to create to
flourish to escape the widespread
poverty and suffering that exists in the
world today and to succeed in that old
All Too Human pursuit of happiness
it is terrifying because of the power
that super intelligent AGI wields to
destroy human civilization intentionally
or unintentionally
the power to suffocate the human spirit
in the totalitarian way of George
Orwell's 1984 or the pleasure fueled
Mass hysteria of Brave New World where
as Huxley saw it people come to love
their oppression to adore the
technologies that undo their capacities
to think
that is why these conversations with the
leaders engineers and philosophers both
optimists and cynics is important now
these are not merely technical
conversations about AI these are
conversations about power about
companies institutions and political
systems that deploy check and balance
this power about distributed economic
systems that incentivize the safety and
human alignment of this power
about the psychology of the engineers
and leaders that deploy AGI and about
the history of human nature our capacity
for good and evil at scale
I'm deeply honored to have gotten to
know and to have spoken with on and off
the mic with many folks who now work at
open AI including Sam Altman Greg
Brockman Elias at skever
wochek zaramba Andre karapathi Jacob uh
pachaki and many others it means the
world that Sam has been totally open
with me willing to have multiple
conversations including challenging ones
on and off the mic
I will continue to have these
conversations to both celebrate the
incredible accomplishments of the AI
community and the steel man the critical
perspective on major decisions various
companies and leaders make always with
the goal of trying to help in my small
way if I fail I will work hard to
improve I love you all